In this lesson, we're going to focus on environment lighting when it comes to
baked lighting. There will be a few tips and tricks when it comes to using your
lights and they can still be associated with Lumen. So feel free to stick along
for the ride and check out what we're talking about. So let's get started.
So the initial setup, again, you always want to make sure you take into account
your scalability for your scene, whether you're going to use epic or cinematic
in your settings. You also want to make sure, again, high precision normals are
on. And some of these settings are already on when it comes to Lumen. But when it
comes to a bake scenario, you do need to double check and make sure that things
are set accordingly. You also want to make sure your reflection captures are
high enough to give you the best, highest visual fidelity. If you're using ray
tracing, this also benefits ray tracing.
So in the initial setup, you always also want to look at your lighting quality.
When you start baking, are you doing production? Are you doing high, medium or
preview? Let me show you where those are found.
You can find that setting under build here and we'll see a lighting quality.
Right now, currently I'm in preview. But if I really want to get the highest
reflection quality and bounces, I want to make sure I'm production. So I'm going to
set that to production and I'm going to go ahead and run the build together.
Now we're getting exactly what we need and want out of our bake here at the
highest quality. It's really important for such things as a light mass portal
that you want to be able to be on production. Otherwise, you won't get
exactly what you want. Now, if you're unfamiliar with light mass portals, they
can be placed in a room right where the window or the opening of a door area is
located. So you can see that there's a lot of light mass portals.
So there's a bit more believability between the dark regions and the light
regions. It's kind of like a priority area to make sure that your GI is
working correctly for those two changes. You also want to make sure you always
have a light mass importance volume in your scene. This is really critical when
it comes to light mass global illumination when it comes to using GI bakes,
I should say. So now GPU bakes, GPU bakes are really important to consider
putting this in there. And the reason why is becomes a priority area for how
things are going to be baked and working with your moving characters.
Now, when it comes to regular light mass importance volume in a CPU bake
scenario, you still want it in there because you don't want to bake
necessarily on everything. You want to make sure that you're not going to
bake necessarily on everything. You want a priority area that's honoring your
light mass settings. Really important to consider this, especially if you're
working with terrain. That way Unreal is not working harder than it needs to.
Let's go back to the slides. Under each light that is set to stationary,
you want to make sure you set things to use area shadows for stationary light.
This is really important. Let's talk briefly about the mobility and then
go back to the slides again. Now again, this is specifically for baked lighting
scenarios, but I just want to point this out just in case it wasn't clear in
past classes. I'm going to click on my light source here.
If we scroll up just a little bit details, we'll see that there's static
mobility, stationary, and movable. Unreal gives you a nice brief breakdown when
you float over it. Static is the cheapest and this is again for baked lighting,
for objects that do not move. You can have as many as your computer can
support. We also have stationary. Now stationary can change color and
intensity, but then only be for overlapping at a time because you're
calculating a bounce within a bounce. You're having these lights interact with
each other and you're getting like double bounces if they overlap.
So only four can be supported at a time. We'll talk about this later on.
So just keep that in mind. This is not supported with Lumen,
nor is static. Lumen supports movable and with movable, the Lumen settings
as well as the mesh distance field set in our project settings and our virtual
shadow maps are all supported using this particular light type.
But baking is going to be shadow maps. And as you can see in our project
settings, and we go to rendering, we'll scroll down just a bit and you'll see
shadow maps is supported. Also in this case, screen space is supported
for our dynamic global illumination, which helps support any bakes that we
create. You can also set none and set it later within your post-process
volume. Let's go back to the slides. So when baking your shadows,
you're going to be creating a thing called a shadow or light map.
That light map is baked within the objects, especially if they're static
onto the existing geometry around them. It will create a self shadowing
type of cover of shadow. You can think of it as almost an ambient occlusion
in your texture on an object, but it's baked directly into a thing called
that shadow map. Now, if you need to increase that resolution,
it's best to go into the geometry of that object and use a thing called
override light map resolution. That's going to be the most helpful,
especially for your hero objects. And you want to set it to the
appropriate resolution. Now, if that object is intersecting with other
objects, you need to consider what that resolution is going to be.
We dive in that a little bit later, but what I mean by that is the
resolutions need to be somewhat in the same ballpark, or you run the
risk of getting some blobby shadows.
So working with lights in detail, the reason why you want to turn on
that area shadow map setting, which was mentioned before, that area light
shadow gives you a nice, believable, more of a blurred shadow in your
environment and can soften things out. So it's a little bit more mirroring
what happens in the real world. If you don't, you may get some edgy
shadows. It may not quite be what you want, but you can push this even
further within the light. In the light, you can create a thing called a
source angle under light mass settings. This can be very helpful to
keep things soft. You can also mess with your light source angle in
general. And let me show you where those are at.
Now, some of these topics were covered in other classes and will still
hold true. And what I mean by that is the source angle when you're
working with lumen will soften your shadows just great. But if we're in a
baking scenario and you're not getting the softness that you're looking
for so much with source angle, you can actually go down. And this is what
I meant. You can actually go down underneath your light source angle
and you can soften it up here to get even a better or a softer edge for
your shadows. And again, this is for a baking scenario.
When you create a directional light, you can also tell it to affect your
atmosphere or not. That's really up to you how you want that to be
included. Now, when real, if you have more than one directional light
specifically when it comes to lumen, it will actually ask you for forward
shading priority, basically which light you want to influence the atmosphere
or the other. And it will give you a prompt for that. So just look out for
that. If you're using lumen and you bring in two directional lights.
So working with lighting in detail, you can see here that with that
ability to be able to tell it to affect your atmosphere, you can control a
few things such as cast shadows on clouds, whether it's going to be
atmospheric sunlight enabled. You can control the atmosphere sunlight index,
the cast shadows on the atmosphere, the cast cloud shadows and cloud
scattering luminance scale. All these things are really helpful if you
need to edit things after the fact, after you bring things in.
So lights also have the ability for you to isolate them for influence via
channels. Let me demonstrate that briefly and then we'll get back to the
slides again.
See with this particular light, we want to control exactly his influence on
the environment. So to be able to do that again, like I said, you can use
the thing called channels. So I can type in and look for channels or you can
search in under advanced and you can find the channels for this object.
You can see it here or for this light. And the same thing there. The objects
also have channels too. So if I typed in channels here, you'll see that there
is make sure you get the right piece of geometry. There we go. We'll just
pick up this guy because he's bigger. This one's a clump and combination of
objects. So you can see here we have channels also active. So let's go to
that spotlight for a moment and we're going to tell it to not affect the
world, but to affect maybe channel one. And then I can go to the object next
to it and I can say he's not affected by the world, but also channel one. So
when I move him near the other light or the spotlight, we are now getting them
both to interact with each other. And you can see that they're not affected
by the lights around that around him, but he is affected by this one because
they're both on the same channel. So that actually works with limit two as
well as baking. So working with lights in detail, we demonstrated this in some
of the other classes where we can actually are in our first class. We can
actually change the shape of this light and you can do that several different
ways. So each light has the ability to be able to change the same the shape as
well as the influence on reflective surfaces. You'll see a thing called soft
source radius. So the soft source radius allows you to blur out any shapes that
may come in, particularly with this point light. So we'll talk about this in just
a second, just a quick review because we did talk about this already and a quick
review when it comes to rec lights, because rec lights are pretty handy with
that. So in our scene, if I bring in just a simple point light in here, we have
several different things that we can choose from. And when it comes to this,
we can actually control our source radius. This can soften a bit of our shadows.
Now you got to be careful when it comes to baking. This can actually get
pixelated in your environment and it can a little bit too with lumen, but mostly
here when it comes to baking. So just keep that in mind. If you change those
things, we also have source soft source radius, which I just mentioned earlier,
which will make it so that any reflectivity in the shape, say there's a
circular hot spot that's showing up somewhere. I don't really have shiny
objects here that we actually can soften that up. And we probably can see it if
we bring it over here to this space probe. Let's see if it's going to show up
here. He's not too reflective, but he is a little bit. So that soft source radius,
we can, you can see it shift a little bit. If you look, the highlights become
less sharp. The lower it's sharper, the higher it's softer. So you can actually
mask or hide that hot spot coming in the reflectivity. And then we also have
source length. And we talked about this before in another class. You can make
some tube lighting. You'll notice if we brought in a spotlight into our scene,
the spotlight will give us the ability to be able to go in here and work like a
typical spotlight. We can control your cone angle, outer cone angle, your
inner cone angle. So you get kind of the typical stuff to be able to mess with.
Now your source radius again, you can soften up your shadows as you mess with
this, but be careful not to push things too far. Rec light again is one of my
favorite ones to work with because he has full control when it comes to working
with the, the source width and the source heights and the barn door angle. Now be
careful with this too, because he is the most expensive, but he is fantastic for
fill light information that you're bringing into your scene. It's really
great to work with. You can also bring in a source texture if you need to, but we
currently don't have it where you can hide that shape. So hopefully later on
we'll be able to evolve in that area. There is a thing called sun in sky. So I'm
going to briefly demonstrate this for a second. I'm going to do a new level for a
second here and we'll just do empty level. Now I'm not going to go through all
the steps with this, but I want to show you what this can do. Your sun in sky,
when you bring it in, it gives you immediately a quick lit area, but with the
ability to have a compass in this compass, you can control longitude, latitude,
longitude in time zone, which is really nice if you need that really quickly. You
still want to add a few more things like you could easily just go in here and say,
Hey, I'm going to go to my environment light mixer. I want to add volume at your
cloud and hide fog. So you can add a couple more things if you need to. Oh,
that's really blown out, right? So definitely we can adjust the settings here,
but I wanted to show you that you can pair this up with the other tools you have
for your environment. But this compass is fantastic to be able to work with
because that compass allows us to go in here and he got a little blown out. We
couldn't see him anymore. This allows us to go in here and to control some of
these things such as time of day, the year, and et cetera. Pretty cool.
I do want to mention also with the spotlight, let's pull that spotlight in for a
second. I'm going to pull this up. This spotlight also can connect and you'll
notice is if you scroll down, if you're curious enough, you may have spotted
this. There is an IES profile you can put in here for light profiles. You can put
in an IES texture I should say. And in here we can choose what kind of IES
texture we want. And this actually is used quite a bit for architectural
purposes. But let me boost up the light here so you can see there's a lot of
light in here. So it's kind of blowing things out. But you can see the different
types of shapes you can get out of this, which is pretty cool. So we can do like
90 degrees. We can do it. You can attach this in a game scenario. You can make
this go to like a flashlight or spotlight. Maybe you're looking for someone
and you can really see it here with this particular one. You kind of that
spotlight flashlight kind of look how the lights passing through the glass of
that particular light set up here. And it's pretty cool. So you can add those
which can be pretty helpful. And you can use this also with Lumen too, as well as
in a bake scenario. Now when you're using baking, you do want to make sure that
you're using an ambient occlusion set up here. And this allows you to be able to
add it in your project. So you can actually have it in there. And it's kind
of our almost like a screen space ambient occlusion in our scene and makes things
a little bit easier for you to work with. Now you don't want to turn that you don't
want to have that on for your static lighting, especially when it comes to
Lumen. But in a baking scenario, it's a good idea to play with that, tweak it and
put it on. And you can also have it within your post process volume as a little
help for pushing your visuals. Well, that's it for this one. And the next one
In the next class, we're going to talk about light mass and light maps and a bit
more detail. We did cover it a little bit here, but we're going to get a little bit
more detailed. And then we're going to move on to some other really cool topics.